merci Monsieur le Premier Ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Jean Lassalle
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre Mesdames et Messieurs
mes chers
dans la montagne des
Pyrénées-Atlantiques
150 habitants et des centaines de
milliers d'hectares de plus en plus
voués aux herbes folles de l'oubli
j'ai beaucoup aimé Monsieur le Premier
Ministre lorsque vous avez dit hier
annoncé hier j'espère que ça ça a repris
que la langue politique était une langue
morte j'ai aimé vous ayez mis un exergue
le génie français ce génie français qui
en caractère universaliste et que si
nous le poussons un petit peu plus est
capable de re en semencer à nouveau et
l'Europe et le monde mais je dois dire
que je suis beaucoup plus circonspect
lorsque vous mettez en place vous allez
continuer à mettre en place les trois
immenses intercommunalités par
département pour les trois fauves
dominants de chaque département mal aux
femelles
après avoir été frappé d'americanisation
rampante pendant 30 ans qui a mis
l'Europe dans l'état que vous connaissez
nous voici maintenant frappé de d'une
crise de germanisation aiguë qui veut
mettre en place des Landers pour un État
fédéral alors que nous ne l'avons jamais
été Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous ne
pouvez pas mener ces deux chantiers de
pairs c'est impossible merci la parole
est à Madame Marie-Lise le branchu
ministre de la décentralisation de la
réforme de l'État et de la fonction
publique
merci merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député la salle je n'aurais
sans doute pas les mêmes mots que vous
pour parler de chaque territoire de
France mais je rappelle pour l'avoir
déjà dit et vous étiez présent lors des
débats ici lors de la première partie de
cette loi que j'aurai l'honneur de
porter dans quelques semaines que la
seule solution que nous avions trouvé
ensemble Monsieur le Député Maire
c'était de renforcer les
intercommunalités pour que nos communes
de France puissent savoir suffisamment
de ressources de personnel d'encadrement
d'ingénierie pour ne pas connaître ce
que nous avons connu que nous
connaissons encore c'est à dire la même
mise de ce que vous avez appelé et
d'autres avec vous les bureaux d'études
sur les petites communes sont
personnelles nous avons donc décidé de
renforcer l'intercommunalité nous le
ferons encore lors du deuxième projet de
loi il est important aussi de noter que
vous avez souvent parlé des conseils
généraux comme ceux des conseils
départementaux futurs comme ceux qui
allaient apporter la solidarité
territoriale c'est pour cette raison
monsieur le député que ces conseils
départementaux auront cinq années pour
pouvoir mettre en place une réponse
construite cohérente et solidaire aux
questions qui se posent aujourd'hui aux
communes rurales et peut-être encore
plus aux communes de montagne il faudra
qu'ensemble nous mettions en place ces
outils pour que au terme d'un mandat
nous puissions avoir des
intercommunalités suffisamment fortes
certains disent à l'échelle d'un
arrondissement rien n'est tranché mais
je sais compter sur vous pour que ce
débat soit serein apaisé et constructif
et je vous en remercie
merci Madame la